tf1 20 heures avec dominique baudis la
catastrophe du dc9 d'alitalia palerme le
témoignage bouleversant d'une rescapée
noël à beyrouth une fête parmi les
ruines au terme de quatre ans de guerre
civile
limitation des armes stratégiques
l'américain 27 soviétique gromyko joue
les prolongations à genève politique
c'est l'heure des bilans bruno masure
fait celui de la session parlementaire
martin willoquet libéré sous conditions
elle passera noël auprès de son fils
william né en prison
bonsoir sinistre coïncidence ou bien
rançon du développement du trafic aérien
quoi qu'il en soit l'année 60 18 avait
commencé le 1er janvier dernier par une
catastrophe aérienne
213 morts dans un amerrissage forcé près
de bombay et les derniers jours de la
même année 78 sont marquées par une
autre catastrophe aérienne cette fois
c'est un dc9 d'alitalia qui s'abîme en
mer à quelques kilomètres de l'aéroport
de palerme en sicile parmi les 129
personnes qui se trouvaient à bord seuls
21 survivants été recueillis on dénombre
donc ce soir sans vie morts et disparus
les recherches se sont poursuivies
durant toute la journée dans l'espoir de
retrouver quelques survivants
et puis les enquêteurs se penchent sur
les raisons de l'accident certes
l'aéroport de palerme était réputé
dangereux mais jusqu'à présent les
causes directes de la catastrophe n'ont
pas été élucidées les dernières
précisions avec notre correspondant en
italie club revelli l'avait plus
dangereux du monde n'avait pas été
modernisé depuis la dernière catastrophe
en 1960 en fait par manque d'équipement
il est généralement fermée la nuit au
trafic et à cet égard de cette nuit qui
devait arrivé de rome à une heure du
matin était tout à fait exceptionnelle
et 21 survivants puis la sensée grassi
au milieu de l'avion
en s'abattant sur la mer et d'être ainsi
éjecter les autres auraient leur mot
revenir attaché impuissant à leurs
fauteuils en s'enfonçant dans la mer
classe et par 50 mètres de fond anti
fils
cette catastrophe qui ramenait au pays
des travailleurs immigrés du nord venus
passer en famille noël a provoqué de
bouleversantes scènes de désespoir
collectif rien n'aura été épargné au
calvaire italien ne pouvait lire viens
de vous le dire les vingt-et-une
personnes qui ont échappé à la mort se
trouvaient toutes dans la partie médiane
de l'avion qui s'est disloqué après
avoir heurté la surface de l'eau parmi
ces rescapés une femme dont vous allez
entendre le témoignage
je vous laisse avec avions nous ne
pouvions plus révérés j'ai essayé de
casser le dos mais je ne suis pas arrivé
alors que j'avais perdu tout espoir car
je ne voyais plus ma fille j'étais sûr
que tout était fini
tout s'est passé tellement vite l'avion
s'enfonçait de plus en plus et tout de
suite il a été mon cas
et oh oui j'étais complètement désespéré
je n'avais plus rien à faire pour les
filles que je ne retrouverai jamais
alors j'ai été happé par je ne sais quoi
mais une fausse sortie de l'avion
j'ai continué à chercher et je ne la
trouvais toujours pas j'ai eu envie de
mourir
et puis je les appelais encore et enfin
elle m'a répondu alors que cela m'a
donné l'envi et la force de sortie mais
pour tenter de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé cette nuit au large des côtes de
la sicile où ce décès 9 d'alitalia été
engloutis vous l'avez entendu en
l'espace de quelques secondes
jean-paul flory a interrogé un
commandant de bord sur les conditions
spécifiques d'un accident provocante un
amerrissage forcé est-ce qu'il est plus
difficile de se poser sur l'eau avec un
avion que de se poser sur la terre il
certainement beaucoup plus difficile de
se poser sur l'eau que sur la terre
l'eau est un élément pas naturel pour un
avion
il peut se passer de tas de problèmes
dus à la hauteur des vagues force du
vent et un atterrissage un amerrissage
provoqué l'éclatement de l'avion une
fois l'avion posé sur l'eau qu'est ce
qui se passe il coule
il flotte non un avion si la mairie
sache qui fait dans de bonnes conditions
peut rester dans un délai
très raisonnable la surface de l'eau de
l'ordre de 30 à 45 minutes ce qui permet
une évacuation des passagers dans de
bonnes conditions
comment se passe cette évacuation des
passagers c'est presque automatique sur
ordre du commandant de bord l'équipage
de cabine déclenché les sorties de
secours des escabeaux gonflables se
tendent sur l'eau et permettent
l'évacuation des passagers sur les
canots pneumatiques les canots
pneumatiques équipés pour la survie en
mer les cas très bien équipée pour la
survie en mer des passagers peuvent
rester très longtemps dans ces canaux
ont forcé les passagers à attacher leur
ceinture lors de l'amerrissage
lors d'un amerrissage oui les passagers
doivent immédiatement revêtir leurs
miles west et mettre leur ceinture de
sécurité
leur ceinture de sécurité également et
est ce que c'est pas un petit peu un
piège
pas du tout ça peut régulariser au
contraire l'évacuation de l'avion
l'éviter des encombrements aux
niveau des issues de secours qu'est ce
qui a pu se passer à votre avis parce
que là finalement rien de ce que vous
venez d'expliquer ne s'est passé ne
semble s'être passé en tout cas cet
appareil a dû avoir une avarie très
grave
les avec une perte de contrôle de
l'avion
si bien que l'amerrissage semble s'est
très mal passé puisque l'avion a plus ou
moins éclatée à la surface de l'eau dans
ce cas là qu'est ce qui reste à faire
il ya malheureusement plus rien à faire
cette affiche que vous découvrez sur
votre écran le liban vous dit joyeux
noël quand même cette affiche est sans
doute à l'image de l'état d'esprit des
libanais en cette veille de fête
amertume et espoirs étroitement mêlés
chrétiens ou musulmans
les libanais s'apprêtent à vivre leur
quatrième noël de guerre civile 4 années
d'hostilité entrecoupés de trêve aussi
fragile que brèves un pays martyrisé
déchiré un peuple qui s'efforcent de
survivre
partagés entre l'espoir et la
résignation
alors le liban à la veille de noël vu
par issa pouye
noël sous 118 et paix aux hommes de
bonne volonté à souhait qui au niveau en
prend toute sa valeur dans un pays en
guerre depuis trois ans et qui
aujourd'hui est un tournant de son
histoire
au moment où l'on parle d'implantations
palestinienne ce qui changera
l'équilibré confessionnel qui détermine
les rapports politiques l'idée d'une
fédération entre les différentes
communautés ce que l'on appelle une
décentralisation administrative fait son
chemin
geslin compte en france je les laisse
faire ensemble
de l'amour
nouvelle à beyrouth et fêter avec
discrétion le souvenir des récents
bombardements qui pendant plusieurs
semaines se sont abattues sur les
chrétiens tuant hommes femmes enfants et
détruisant les maisons est encore trop
présent dans les mémoires pour que cet
anniversaire de la naissance du christ
soit un jour de joie et de l'iss
refaire seulement une petite crèche
parce que vous allez ne travaille pas ça
fait six mois alors en faire un petit
crush on you dare à la messe comme
d'habitude
les jeunes de noisette et jouer les
jouets n'y a pas de l'argent ce pour
porter des jouets aux enfants à l'ordre
on passera comme ça
paix aux hommes de bonne volonté les
quelques 2 millions de palestiniens
réfugiés la souhaitent eux qui depuis 30
ans vivent dans l'espoir de retourner
sur leurs terres
parmi ces palestiniens 20% sont
chrétiens pour eux la pince insee plus
de leur pays c'est la terre du christ
beaucoup de leaders palestiniens sont
chrétiens et la plupart ont des
positions politiques extrêmes rêvant
d'un pays où tous les hommes qu'ils
soient musulmans juifs ou chrétiens
puissent vivre en harmonie et accéder
aux postes de responsabilités politiques
qu'il mérite bien qu'on soit leur
religion dans ces camps palestiniens
le père noël sera pauvre cette année une
lan laissera qu'un projet d'implantation
dans des pays étrangers
loin de jérusalem la terre promise et
justement l'année dernière en cette
période de noël la paix semblait se
profiler à l'horizon de la crise née de
la crise du proche orient
rappelez vous sa date s'était rendu
quelques semaines plus tôt à jérusalem
et le 25 décembre
il s'apprête à accueillir en egypte le
premier ministre israélien menahem begin
l'optimisme de certains pouvaient faire
croire que la paix était à portée de la
main mais depuis lors que de temps
écoulé et si peu de chemin parcouru
certes il y a eu le spectaculaire sonné
de comme david mais là encore les
résultats n'ont pas été à la mesure des
espérances
aux termes des accords de camp david la
paix devrait déjà être signé entre
l'egypte et israël
est il besoin de rappeler que l'on en
est encore très loin
alors pour tenter de sauver ce qui peut
encore être sauvé le premier ministre
égyptien monsieur khalil et le ministre
israélien des affaires étrangères
monsieur dyan vont s'efforcer de
relancer les pourparlers de paix à
l'occasion d'un mini sommet à bruxelles
et cyrus vance le chef de la diplomatie
américaine participera dès demain à
cette réunion dans la capitale belge
cyrus vance qui vient de quitter genève
où il a négocié âprement avec son
homologue soviétique monsieur gromyko là
encore il était question de paix
puisqu'il s'agissait des accords salt
ces fameux accord sur la limitation des
armements nucléaires on avait espéré la
conclusion d'un accord pour ce soir et
là aussi l'espérance a été déçu les deux
hommes se sont heurtés à des difficultés
de dernière minute
jacqueline du bois oui pour le moment
c'est un échec on vient de l'apprendre à
l'instant cyrus vans et andrei gromyko
vient de se séparer
et pourtant ces deux hommes ont tout
fait pour pouvoir aboutir à un accord
ces soldes piétine depuis six ans signé
en 1972 il prévoyait l'arrêt presque
totale de la course aux armements
stratégiques de l'union soviétique et
des états unis
mais ni le kremlin ni la maison blanche
non respecté l'accord les américains ont
bien abandonner la majoration les vois
mal des stratégiques bien mais ils ont
mis au point une arme terrible le cloud
mais sauf avions sans pilote à longue
portée volant à basse altitude et
échappant ainsi toute détection les
soviétiques de leur côté ont fabriqué un
bombardier redoutable le bac brun
capable d'atteindre les états unis
si les ravitailler en vol une bonne
partie de la controverse soviéto
américaine concernant la limitation des
armements stratégiques portent depuis
deux ans sous les bacs fin et les crous
aujourd'hui il faut espérer que les
négociations reprendront prochainement
si demain ce traité signé il établira
non seulement une parité numérique des
arsenaux stratégiques nucléaires des
deux superpuissances
il consacrera aussi une réduction de
l'enfance et il est convenu qu'un sommet
blush nafta faire suivre à la signature
de ce traité
oui américains et soviétiques devons
donc prendre à nouveau rendez vous pour
tenter de dégager un accord définitif
c'est sans doute l'une des conditions de
la sécurité du monde car sinon sinon
tout peut-être imaginer tout y compris
le pire comme ce scénario de politique
fiction
conçu par un stratège britannique un
reportage de michel v
la troisième guerre mondiale commence au
début de l'été 1985 en yougoslavie
le pays s'est rapproché du camp
occidental après la mort de tito les
soviétiques réagissent rapidement le 27
juillet 1985 une division de
parachutistes soviétique s'empare de
belgrade
le président des états unis en voici
marine saoudienne
vingt-quatre heures après les marines
américains combattent les troupes
parachutistes russes cet incident donne
au commandement russe le prétexte
longtemps attendu ses troupes
envahissent l'allemagne fédérale et la
scandinavie
leur objectif le rhin les premiers chars
soviétiques t-72 et t-90 franchissent la
frontière de la république fédérale
allemande en formation serrée
le matin du 4 août 1985 l'offensive
alliée du 15 août met en échec les
troupes du pacte de varsovie
les soulèvements populaires éclatent
partout en urss certaine division russe
commence à se mutiner
les soviétiques doivent évacuer
l'allemagne à moscou les faucons décide
d'utiliser le feu nucléaire
le matin du 20 août un missile est 16-17
explose au centre le birmingham en
grande-bretagne trois cent mille
personnes meurent en quelques minutes
quelques heures plus tard deux missiles
américains anéantissent minsk en urss
la peur de la guerre nucléaire totale
déclenché une révolte des nationalités
en urss qui porte un coup fatal au
système soviétique
la troisième guerre mondiale a duré
moins de trois semaines
le scénario n'est pas dû à un auteur de
science-fiction mais à l'un des
meilleurs experts militaires occidentaux
le général à kate
et
non
le général hackett ancien commandant de
l'armée britannique durera nous dit
pourquoi il a écrit le livre publié à
londres sous le titre la troisième
guerre mondiale août 85
ce n'est pas une prévision pas du tout
je suis pas prophète mais ce cirque
si dans nos pays de l'ouest de
l'alliance atlantique
nous nous faisons beaucoup mieux nous ne
faisons à présent pendant tes défense
que dans un tel cas notre état serait
très très difficile
tout le monde n'est pas du même avis les
responsables politiques de l'otan''
pense que le général pak est sûre estime
le potentiel de l'armée rouge
en tout cas on ne pourra pas accuser le
général keith de manquer d'humour
interrogé sur le point de savoir
pourquoi il avait choisi birmingham
comme objectif de la bombe atomique
russe
il a répondu je n'ai jamais aimé
birmingham martine wille hockey qui
avait été condamné en mars 77 à deux
peines de cinq ans de réclusion vient de
bénéficier d'une mesure de libération
conditionnelle la chancellerie considère
que martine wille hockey a donné des
gages de bonne réinsertion sociale et la
chancellerie a fait savoir qu'il ne
s'agissait pas d'une grâce ou d'une
remise de peine mais d'une mesure de
clémence destiné à permettre à martin
ville au quai de passer les fêtes de fin
d'année auprès de son fils l'avocat de
martine wille hockey m jura me a
qualifié cette mesure de geste
humanitaire il y voit tonate de
politique pénitentiaire raisonnable et
avancer vengeance aveugle et tragique à
rouen serge duval âgé de 34 ans a
poignardé mortellement son avocat maître
jean mars serge duval l'ancien client de
la victime reproché à son avocat de
n'avoir pas obtenu la garde de ses
enfants d'après certaines informations
le meurtrier ne serait pas en possession
de toutes ses facultés mentales
passée la période des fêtes les
parlementaires vont se remettre au
travail la session extraordinaire du
parlement va en effet se prolonger dans
les premiers jours de janvier
députés et sénateurs examineront donc au
début de l'année prochaine
le projet de loi relatif à l'aide aux
travailleurs privés d'emploi et depuis
le début du mois d'octobre
on a déjà compté très exactement 400 six
heures de séance à l'assemblée nationale
si 100 au sénat et plus de quatre mille
amendements ont été discutées et comme
chaque fois à la fin d'une session
parlementaire députés et sénateurs se
plaignent amèrement des méthodes et du
rythme de travail qui leur interdisent i
still un examen approfondi des textes
législatifs
par exemple pour le président du sénat
monsieur poher la cote d'alerté est
atteinte et il faudrait allonger la
durée des sessions alors le bilan de
cette session justement avec bruno
masure le plat de résistance de cette
session était bien évidemment le vote du
budget 79 qui à occuper les députés
pendant deux cents
10 heures les sénateurs 170 472
milliards de dépenses un déficit de 15
milliards
ce débat a rituels les parlementaires ne
peuvent guère modifier les propositions
du gouvernement a été aussi fastidieux
qu'à l'ordinaire il a tout de même donné
lieu à quelques échanges intéressants
par exemple lors du vote du budget de la
justice un mini débat s'est engagé sur
la peine de mort
le véritable débat devrait en principe
avoir lieu au printemps le rpr à grenier
devant les projets jean pierre soisson
en matière d'éducation physique
le vote du budget d'éducation a été
accompagnée d'importantes manifestations
d'enseignants et de parents d'élèves et
le rpr rec m'arrête à refuser de
rapporter le budget des affaires
étrangères pour protester contre les
déclarations de louis guy ringot sur le
liban quarante-et-une lois ont été
votées par l'assemblée le sénat portant
sur les sujets les plus variés de la
réglementation de la publicité dans les
rues au statut de wallis et futuna en
passant par le prix de l'eau ou des
loyers ou la retraite des avocats
les parlementaires ont également
beaucoup travaillé sur des textes très
complexes concernant les finances
locales
le rapport d'adaptation du 7e plan ou la
réforme de l'exécution des peines
l'instauration d'un régime de sûreté et
la restriction des permissions de sortir
dans une conjoncture économique
difficile les parlementaires ont ouvert
d'importants dossiers sociaux et
financiers
l'occasion pour un grand nombre de
députés rpr de manifester leurs réserves
voire leurs critiques sur la politique
économique de raymond barre même s'il
approuvait finalement les projets du
gouvernement
par exemple lors du vote sur le plan de
sauvetage de la sidérurgie députés les
sénateurs ont également discuté un grand
nombre de textes sur l'emploi la réforme
de l'indemnisation du chômage ou encore
les 50 heures hebdomadaires maximum
enfin un grand nombre de débats ont été
organisés au palais bourbon au palais du
luxembourg
sans vote sur la politique agricole la
catastrophe de l'amoco cadiz le liban et
surtout l'europe et le problème de
l'élargissement de la communauté
c'est aussi européen a provoqué la seule
véritable surprise de cette session par
deux fois en effet l'udf a été isolé
la première fois le rpr a ajouté ses
voix à celles de la gauche sur un texte
proposant l'harmonisation de la tva dans
les pays européens
après les explications rassurantes du
premier ministre le rpr a rapporté son
vote
la deuxième fois le rpr a récidivé en
votant avec le pc un texte interdisant
le financement de la prochaine campagne
européenne sur des fonds d'origine
communautaire mais comme le sénat a
refusé d'examiner ce texte ce texte ne
sera finalement pas voté
pas de surprise par contre lors de la
discussion de la mosson censure proposé
par le ps 199 voix seulement pour
l'ensemble de la gauche
la prochaine session risque d'être
beaucoup plus agitée juste après les
cantonales et pendant la campagne
européenne
mais jacques chirac a promis que le rpr
maintiendrait la trêve avec le
gouvernement saviez vous que cette année
2544 équipe de football se sont engagés
dans la coupe de france il n'en reste
déjà plus que 128 en lice et elles
s'affrontent durant ce week-end pour le
7e tour de cette coupe de france est à
ce stade de la compétition que les
équipes de deuxième division entre temps
lice et c'est aussi le début de la
grande aventure pour les cinq qualifiés
d league d'outre-mer l'un de ces clubs
représentant la guadeloupe jouer cet
après midi dans la région parisienne
un reportage de georges de ministre
football c'est ce qui arrive
actuellement aux footballeurs de la
gauloise basse-terre représentants de la
guadeloupe de la coupe de france
les guadeloupéens qui affronte
aujourd'hui l'équipe parisienne de
poissy
vous avez 17 ans vous êtes le plus jeune
de la gauloise vous suivez beaucoup
d'équipés en métropole oui bien sûr
particulièrement à strasbourg
et quels sont vos joueurs préférés en
métropole batni
c'est combien actuellement point de vue
degré envoie de l'eau et aux alentours
de 30 depuis vous allez vers mon entrée
avec un moral de vainqueur et la
gauloise a pour habitude toujours se
présenter en vigueur ce pas dire on va
gagner à tous les coups
les guadeloupéens eu quelques angoisses
en début de match il faisait 5 degrés
sous zéro cet après-midi à saint-ouen
mais les russes s'y accoutumer revient
vite et juste avant la mi temps
le miracle se produisit un clip super de
bassin plein carrière les guadeloupéens
mène 1 à 0 dans les tribunes tam tam et
punch vont être à l'honneur joie
partagée aux antilles où la radio
retransmet la partie intégralement
les jaunes de poissy occuperont souvent
le combat du père deuxième mi temps mais
la gauloise tiendra jusqu'au bout
toujours en le prochain tour chez eux en
espérant accueillir saint-etienne nantes
ou strasbourg le temps demain il sera
froid sur le nord le nord-est le jura et
la savoie on enregistrera des gelées de
-2 à -4 ailleurs il pleuvra à
l'exception des côtes méditerranéennes
au delà de 1000 mètres en montagne on
prévoit des chutes de neige et ajoutons
que la nuit de noël devrait être assez
douces mais attendez-vous cependant à du
vent et à des chutes de pluie comment
devient ton restaurateur d'oeuvres d'art
jusqu'à présent en france les choses se
fassent se passer de façon quelque peu
empirique les restaurateurs apprenez
leur métier à l'étranger ou bien tout
simplement sur le tas en se faisant la
main jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient acquis
l'expérience nécessaire mais désormais
la france dispose d'un centre de
formation des restaurateur d'oeuvres
d'art comme c'était d'ailleurs déjà le
cas chez la plupart de nos voisins
européens ce centre vient d'être
inaugurée par jean philippe lecat
ministre de la culture et de la
communication dans l'ancien atelier des
gobelins un reportage de christiane de
la croix-rousse yeux c'est la racine un
moment où l'érosion matériel de notre
patrimoine artistique ne peut que
s'aggraver sérieusement il était urgent
que soit créé cet institut français apte
à former des restaurateurs de très haut
niveau
le soulever vous voyez bien bien bien
toutes leurs jeunes comment étaient ils
seront les médecins des grandes oeuvres
d'art dont certaines se découpent se
fissure s'efface ou ce club
il leur appartiendra donc de les
nettoyer de les retoucher de leur
redonner leur beauté première sans leur
faire courir aucun risque sur 120
candidats sélectionnés selon des tests
d'aptitude 20 ont été admis au concours
d'entrée
tous bénéficient d'une bourse moyenne
d'âge 20 à 35 ans en quatre ans ils
doivent acquérir ici une solide
formation scientifique dans la
connaissance des techniques anciennes
comme dans celle des techniques de
pointe avec toute la prudence qui exige
l'application de produits de synthèse à
la préservation des grandes collections
publiques
cinq ateliers sont ouverts peintures
sculptures mobilier céramique et
techniques des matériaux un métier
choisi pour l'amour de l'art ingénieur
en économie quand j'ai commencé à
restaurer avec mon père mais il manquait
tout le côté scientifique j'ai envie de
pratiquer pour moi est de restituer les
délais
de vivre avec la matière d'autres
ateliers seront sans doute ouvert d'ici
un an ou deux car il s'agit bien de
former des restaurateurs mais surtout en
fonction de certains débouchés de
certains marchés cette entreprise a été
voulue par le ministère de la culture en
liaison directe avec les utilisateurs
c'est à dire les musées on a dit de cet
institut qu'il formerait les énarques de
la restauration
est ce dire il ne sera accessible qu'à
un certain cercle restreint une certaine
élite
donc plutôt que les élèves de la
restauration je parlerai des normaliens
supérieur de la restauration car en fait
nous désirons former des formateurs
est-ce qu'il sera quand même possible à
certains restaurateurs qui ont été
formés sur le tas de se recycler écoutez
vous poser le problème qui est notre
préoccupation majeure à savoir après la
mise en place de cette formation
initiale nous allons nous occuper dès
1979 de la mise en place de la formation
professionnelle continue et recyclage
recyclage alors les décors de films à
grand spectacle par exemple sont ils des
oeuvres d'art c'est à vous d'en juger
avec ce reportage de six leviers qui a
visité le plateau de tournage du
prochain james bond
sachez toutefois que la dernière
production de la série l'espion qui
m'aimait avait coûté 70 millions de
francs recettes 700 millions de francs
un rapport de 1 à 10 alors encouragé par
ces résultats les producteurs engagent
cette fois 150 millions de francs sur ce
tournage dont certaines séquences en
réaliser aux studios d'epinay
il y à des films pour lesquels le décor
n'est pas très important il y à d'autres
films pour lesquels ce décor est
primordial c'est bien sûr le cas des
james bond alors cette année le cinéma
français a le privilège
en tout économique d'accueillir le
tournage de moonraker qu'allez-vous
faire du décor à la fin du tournage mais
on va le détruire
comme toujours dans ce décor là il y a
des grandes explosions et tout ça parce
que dans l'histoire on va détruire des
décors mais de toute façon une fois
finie on détruit les décors le nouveau
james bond sera donc un film ayant trait
à l'espace et ce décor reconstitué une
station spatiale de trois étages 220
ouvriers ont participé à sa réalisation
deux tonnes de cloud 100 tonnes de
ferrailles 300 mètres cubes de loi est
un équipement électronique correspondant
à celui de 4 jumbo jets ont été utilisés
qena dans a déjà 7 james bond à son
actif si les décors de golf une guerre
sur ce qu'il a préféré se de moonraker
sont les plus grandioses qu'il ait pu
créer un décor de 3 millions 500 mille
francs détruit dès la fin du tournage
n'est ce pas un peu triste
non pas du tout pour moi une fois je
suis très content de devoir mon décor
une fois finie si on a bien tourné le
décor je suis assez contente qu'on
que ça va disparaître parce que je veux
commencer avec une autre type de décor
après v ne se fait pas du tout
sentimentale pour les écoles voilà ce
journal est maintenant terminée toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité vous souhaite
de passer une excellente soirée une
soirée au terme de laquelle vous pourrez
retrouver jacques poulx pour notre toute
dernière édition
bonsoir et à demain